Speaker 1: The moon is out, everyone's in dreamland, and you've tuned into The Deb of
Speaker 1: Night.
Speaker 1: Nobody to fall asleep next to?
Speaker 1: Go ahead and pull the radio into bed.
Speaker 1: That's what I'm here for.
Speaker 1: And hey, why don't you call me sometime?
Speaker 1: Area code three two three, KL5 KTRK.
Speaker 1: Looks like somebody's been waiting in the queue quite a while to speak to
Speaker 1: yours truly.
Speaker 1: So, caller, why aren't you asleep?
Speaker 2: Um, uh, insects.
Speaker 1: Insects, as in you have an insect problem, or chirping crickets are keeping you
Speaker 1: up, or you have nightmares about them?
Speaker 1: Help me out here.
Speaker 2: No, no, no.
Speaker 2: Don't you know, when you fall asleep, they can crawl into your mouth or
Speaker 2: your ears or, or your nose.
Speaker 2: Y- you can't prevent it if you're asleep.
Speaker 2: I, I mean, what can you do?
Speaker 1: Are there any scientists out there listening to this?
Speaker 2: Um, I, I, I read something, I, I don't know where, but do you
Speaker 2: know the average person eats several pounds of insects a year?
Speaker 2: The majority of that weight is composed of roaches, ants, and spiders.
Speaker 2: Just knowing that as soon as you close your eyes, a big, fat centipede
Speaker 2: is gonna drop into your mouth and crawl down your throat, [panting] I can't
Speaker 2: do it.
Speaker 2: I never sleep at night.
Speaker 1: You know, they voluntarily eat insects in some countries.
Speaker 2: Yeah, well, those countries probably need Jesus.
Speaker 1: So you never sleep at night.
Speaker 1: I assume you do sleep, right?
Speaker 2: Uh, I sleep at work.
Speaker 1: And what exactly do you do?
Speaker 2: I'm a middle school teacher.
Speaker 1: That would explain why my nephew invested that twenty I sent him for his
Speaker 1: birthday on magic beans.
Speaker 1: It's always good to know that the future of our country is in good
Speaker 1: hands, isn't it?
Speaker 1: Oh, boy.
Speaker 1: Let's see who else we got.
Speaker 1: Caller, what do you do for a living?
Speaker 3: I'm Roger.
Speaker 1: Okay, and what do you do, Roger?
Speaker 3: Um, I'm a writer, Deb.
Speaker 1: So have you written any, uh, movies I might have seen?
Speaker 3: Well, I actually haven't finished any screenplays yet.
Speaker 1: I see.
Speaker 1: So have you done any other kinds of writing?
Speaker 3: Well, just some outlines right now, but I got some really good ideas for
Speaker 3: some stories that are crawling around in the old noggin.
Speaker 1: [laughs] So if you haven't really written anything, how can you call yourself a
Speaker 1: writer?
Speaker 1: Because I once fixed my toilet doesn't make me a plumber, right?
Speaker 3: Well, you see-
Speaker 1: Is there anyone in this city that doesn't call themselves a writer or actor
Speaker 1: or director?
Speaker 1: Don't you think you're doing a disservice to those who actually make their living
Speaker 1: in those art forms by deeming yourself something you're not or not even trained
Speaker 1: to do?
Speaker 3: Um, no.
Speaker 3: [laughs] I think I'm pretty good at knowing what's good writing from bad writing.
Speaker 1: Well, wouldn't that make you a critic?
Speaker 1: Let's see if anyone else agrees.
Speaker 1: Line two, are you ready for a ménage à trois?
Speaker 4: Sure thing, Deb.
Speaker 1: And would you please state what you do for a living?
Speaker 4: I'm a personal assistant for a producer at Parasite Studios.
Speaker 1: Perfect.
Speaker 1: Do you read a lot of screenplays?
Speaker 4: Don't get me started.
Speaker 1: Well, for our writer on the phone, here's your big chance to pitch your
Speaker 1: screenplay.
Speaker 1: Is that okay, line two?
Speaker 4: Sell me, dude.
Speaker 3: Well, um, okay.
Speaker 3: So, uh, my story's about this guy.
Speaker 4: You don't say.
Speaker 3: Okay, o- okay.
Speaker 3: So this guy, he's, well, he's like a, an FBI agent, but, you know,
Speaker 3: he doesn't really work for the main FBI.
Speaker 3: And, um, he's got this partner who's new and really cute, but she's also
Speaker 3: a really good agent, and they're, like, assigned to this bizarre case where people
Speaker 3: are being killed in really strange ways.
Speaker 4: Uh-huh.
Speaker 3: And then, like, something happens, and the girl agent gets kidnapped by the killer.
Speaker 4: Something happens.
Speaker 3: Yeah, well, I haven't quite figured it out yet, but, like, the guy agent
Speaker 3: notices, like, how the killer seems to know everything he's doing, like, one step
Speaker 3: ahead of him, and then there's this kinda, you know, weird chase scene, and
Speaker 3: then, like, we find out that the guy's got two personalities, and, like, he
Speaker 3: finds out in the end that he's the killer, and then he's kidnapped his
Speaker 3: own partner.
Speaker 1: Well, line two, what do you think?
Speaker 1: You gonna option it or not?
Speaker 4: Uh, writer dude?
Speaker 3: Roger.
Speaker 4: Uh, Roger, would you like my professional opinion?
Speaker 3: Yeah.
Speaker 4: Where are you from?
Speaker 3: Um, Wisconsin.
Speaker 4: Okay.
Speaker 4: I want you to get all your stuff together, and then I want you
Speaker 4: to move back to Wisconsin.
Speaker 1: That's a little cold, line two.
Speaker 4: That's Hollywood, baby.
Speaker 3: Maybe it's just too good for you.
Speaker 4: Uh, no, dude, it's not.
Speaker 1: Break it up, you two.
Speaker 1: Final thoughts, guys?
Speaker 4: Wisconsin.
Speaker 3: I have some other things I'm working on, too.
Speaker 3: I got some pretty good ideas for video games, I think.
Speaker 3: If anyone's interested in hiring me, my number is two one three-
Speaker 1: Sorry, Roger, the only one that gets to give out their number on this
Speaker 1: show is me.
Speaker 1: And if anyone was thinking of asking what I'm wearing, that number again is
Speaker 1: three two three KL5 KTRK.
Speaker 1: We're gonna take a short commercial break, but that doesn't mean you can stop
Speaker 1: thinking about me.
Speaker 1: Don't go anywhere, boys.
Speaker 5: Does your penis always seem to be getting in the way?
Speaker 6: I got the last of the groceries, honey.
Speaker 6: I just need to close the trunk.
Speaker 6: [trunk slams] [screams]
Speaker 7: One more nail and this birdhouse will be as good as new.
Speaker 7: [hammer hits finger] [yells]
Speaker 8: I'm sorry, sir.
Speaker 8: This dressing room is for women only.
Speaker 9: You don't have to let this happen to you.
Speaker 9: Hi, I'm Dr.
Speaker 9: Fred Tuck.
Speaker 9: Don't let your penis interfere with the quality of your life anymore.
Speaker 9: I have performed over three hundred sex changes in my career, and not one
Speaker 9: of my patients has ever asked for their tackle box back.
Speaker 9: Come to Tuck's Sex Exchange in the next month, and I'll give you a
Speaker 9: free estimate.
Speaker 9: Don't let your piece interfere with your peace of mind.
Speaker 5: Tuck's Sex Exchange, located off Beverly Drive.
Speaker 5: Look for the sign with Toothy, the surgical saw.
Speaker 5: Tired of sluggish internet access?
Speaker 1: Mom, the internet's all slow again.
Speaker 8: I'm not your mom.
Speaker 8: I'm the creature that evolved out of your mom.
Speaker 5: Sick of unwanted spam?
Speaker 6: Oh, oh, another email message from my old college roommate, Rod
Speaker 6: Eugies.
Speaker 6: Oh, oh my.
Speaker 5: Computer problems make it frustrating to log on?
Speaker 7: Error four three two network access remote server memory allocation assessment table
Speaker 7: exceeded.
Speaker 7: Hard drive reformatting will now commence.
Speaker 7: What?
Speaker 5: Looking for something that requires no logons, no unwanted email, coherent sentences, and no
Speaker 5: technical problems whatsoever?
Speaker 5: Read a book.
Speaker 5: Books, the original internet.
Speaker 5: Terrorists are prepared to destroy the largest dam in America again.
Speaker 6: Then she-bomb goes off.
Speaker 6: This Hoover will be caught with his panties down.
Speaker 5: And only this renegade cop and his ex-wife's manicurist stand between destruction
Speaker 5: and unexpected love.
Speaker 8: I'll just file you as DOA.
Speaker 8: [gunshot]
Speaker 5: This summer, all bets are off, the heat is on, the fix is in,
Speaker 5: the dogs are out, the game is up, the chips are down, the stakes
Speaker 5: are high, the odds are low, the danger is huge, the payoff is slim.
Speaker 5: Friendships will be made.
Speaker 5: Rules will be broken.
Speaker 5: Wrongs will be righted.
Speaker 5: And no unturned stone will be left.
Speaker 5: Uh, get ready to be turned inside out and upside down.
Speaker 5: [bomb explodes] Hoover 2: Hydro Electric Boogaloo, the best damn
Speaker 5: movie you'll see this year.
Speaker 1: When I'm grinding the reverse Poindexter 540 to ollie northbound to Contraband, I can't
Speaker 1: think about being bloated.
Speaker 1: [stomach gurgles] That's why every morning I down a Pound Ground, the gentle extreme laxative
Speaker 1: sports drink.
Speaker 1: Because when you're pulling a wicked skull cross seven-twenty, you don't want anything to
Speaker 1: slow you down.